[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm working on a new film where i have
to make use of this phantom flex camera
this crazy camera shoots super slow
motion like a thousand frames and more
but i have no idea how it works
therefore i'm going to lock myself in my
studio and shoot
until i get the hang of it and while
doing so it's time for a well-overdue
studio tour
[Music]
this video is brought to you by my
friends at storyblocks the complete
stock solution for creators and
businesses alike
providing unlimited downloads to a
library of high quality
royalty-free video audio and images
through cost-effective subscription
plans
i use them all the time so if you
support me go over and support them too
i know there are a lot of questions
around what it is that i actually do and
in all honesty it'll sound pretty boring
just
telling you in words so i'm going to
show you
[Music]
joe films is now officially open for
business named after joe boy
welcome to our studio where we make
[Music]
music
[Music]
we shoot not
that kind of shooting with cameras
[Music]
we skateboard
we plan things
i'm hungry
[Music]
so
[Music]
we direct tv ads
documentaries and movies
we do social media stuff
we also do our own stunts
[Music]
um
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed my studio twitter now
i'm just going to tell you a little bit
more about my friends at storybox
storyblocks is the sponsor of this video
and just such a great way to speed up
your creative process
their site really does have the highest
quality stock footage textures
illustrations
everything you need to do what you do
best or essentially tell a story in the
most visual way with the unlimited
library over one million assets strong
all yours to download and use anywhere
you're bound to find what you need with
the unlimited all-access subscription
plan
and what's even better is all the
high-speed shots you saw in this video
will be available in 4k on storyblocks
site so click on the link in the
description below
to sign up today other than that don't
forget
you're awesome bru and i'll see you next
i week i
never